[Music]
when you take a wriggly first things
come to your mind is grass he'd mark he
out front and this whole board it's like
one of the main body parts of Wrigley
Field I'm Darrell Wilson I'm a
scoreboard operator for Chicago Cubs
[Music]
I've been working at Wrigley Field since
1987 Brittany Phillips one of the oldest
ballpark besides Boston it's been around
for over a hundred years and basically
nothing has changed in the school board
since 1938 and the school board we have
least three guys if we're lucky for what
a Cubs game is going on my job is to
post scores anybody ending and pitching
changes throughout the league
[Music]
once all the games start in the school
board it's pretty chaotic your writing
scores down on your clipboard and you
change the scores while you're also
yelling at other guys to change their
scores and their games gets it oh it's
hot it's very noisy the walkways are
look narrow you got plates numbers
everywhere the switch up the scoreboard
plate starts with a shift
punch just three tips to pop it out of
the slots the plates are made of a
lighter thin metal if you definitely
have the latch you want to make sure
that they're locked in so that the winds
blowing out they won't blow out at you
or something like that you're running up
and down and change the scores for eight
different games oh it's definitely hard
work if viewers outstanding is it's just
like a 306 degree view of the entire
ballpark and enable it that's like
looking out to your backyard and have
the perfect lawn I mean that's that's
what it's feel like walking out you just
feel feel proud you know you're just
proud of your work and the work that you
guys put into it the reason why I
believe that the school board is special
to fans because it still keeps that old
luster of the old-time ballpark I seen a
lot of modern parks but we really feel
has an authentic original feel of how
baseball began
[Music]
I had no idea what apartments for us and
then I saw it I was like mama why didn't
you get me one and now I'm doing bar
mitzvahs booked out three years in
advance my name is Kareem wells and
everybody called me the King on a missus
I want to share part of my heart and a
part of my life
when I was 16 I had my first kid I was
kicked out of high school so I did what
most people my age did I turned to the
streets I started selling drugs I chose
that because I felt like I had no other
option
I grew up on the west side of Chicago in
the neighborhood where it was a lot of
violence drug dealer a lot of illegal
activity this is West Garfield Park and
this is where my house used to be they
tore it down it is just a lot I had
dreams you know of doing music and I
loved performance the OGIS from the
neighborhood they encouraged me to get
out they pushed me to follow my dream
this guy we knew he was gonna make it
and he managed to pull that one off man
and I'm not proud of the man the thing
that the neighborhood gave me was
toughness and how to hustle never give
up so when I'm out here doing these bar
mitzvahs I'm gonna be strong with it you
know I'm gonna give 200% I'm gonna be
the best at it well is everybody all
right
yeah let's just meet real quick and just
talk about what we gonna do the way that
I got involved in the midst for business
well I got a call one day from a half
brother who told me that there was this
party going on and he said we needed
answer so I go over there and I see
what's going on I actually thought it
was a 50th birthday party but it turns
out that it was a party for a 13 year
old boy
what's up the people saw the way we was
doing parties the way we was bringing
the energy the way we carried I said
with the kids we carried ourselves with
the families it was like we gotta get
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen when you walk into a party that
I'm emceeing you're gonna feel the
energy the moment you walk in the room
and it's gonna be wild and crazy and
everybody's gonna be having the time of
their life we can celebrate just about
thinking a crazy night if your memory
that that kid will never forget you have
some haters that think it's kind of
funny that a black kid from the West
Side of Chicago is doing bar mitzvahs I
say to them I'm the best in my shoes and
I get to experience life at a level that
I never expected I would be I never
thought in a million years that I would
be the owner of an entertainment company
for Bar Mitzvahs I am living proof that
you can come from absolutely some very
horrendous circumstances and you can
make some money yourself if you never
give up the success that this has
brought me it put me in a peaceful place
I'm getting paid to make people happy
today is insane and I just feel great
you
prostitues are you joking I'm an anomaly
in this scene for sure I'm Emma McKee
and I'm across such artists they create
custom one-of-a-kind crosses jackets for
Chicago's creative class
[Music]
cross stitch is a antiquated form of
stitching traditionally done by your
grandma I fell backwards into it
I made a present for my mom a couple
years ago so I taught myself out of
cross stitch it came very naturally to
me and so I decided to do more I felt
compelled to do it but I didn't know
what to do it for other than the obvious
connection was well I'll do it for the
things that inspire me and the things
that I loved were art and poetry and
music Chancellor rappers like the Prince
of Chicago you know he's Chicago royalty
chances one of my favorite rappers and
so I made this jacket it was a three
jacket whose chances three I was like
okay I'll put this on Twitter we'll see
what this does like 30 seconds later
Chancellor Everest followed you chance
to represent you at the end I mean he's
like yo how do I get this and I was like
any way you want and he warned on the
cover of Billboard and that was kind of
like how it started this it's for an
artist they make Jenkins so hard I've
made something like a hundred and
thirty-five pieces in the last four
years some of the people I've made stuff
for this is a Major Lazer
chance the rapper quick Mensa most def
Joy / Kendrick Lamar oh yeah little
Gaddy of course how could I forget about
lil yachty but the majority of them are
worn by people who are not famous a lot
of people I make stuff for in Chicago
where there's stuff every day live in
the things cross-stitch is just a cross
stitched it's just a square you
basically take an image and you pixelate
the hell out of it
so you map out a bunch of tiny squares
it takes a very good spatial recognition
a lot of patience and you cannot mess it
up my inspiration usually will come
complete finished everything from a
person it arrives in my head fully
formed and that's it I have no idea how
we get there I don't sit around and
think about it for somebody like the way
that I'm able to make something for
somebody as if it is there I have to go
out to the suburbs to buy my thread it's
all specialty I spend an ungodly amount
of money on thread it would freak you
out I always say like the median amount
of time and a jacket is anywhere from
like 50 to 60 hours when you're done
then you get to pull the graph out and
then you could see what it looks like
when it's finished
[Music]
people call what's happening in Chicago
or Renaissance we have art and we have
music and we have all these people
making positive changes all these people
making incredible incredible stuff I
have a team that oscillates anywhere
from like 7 to 14 people and they're all
artists they're all other Chicago
artists well we do these big photo
shoots with people who's like really the
only way that I can't along anything is
by having pictures of it the giving away
part is the best part to see something
that you've made affect somebody in what
seems to be a meaningful way is a pretty
emotional thing the goal with the
crosses checkups is never to sell them
or to make money off of them it's truly
truly a passion project
I'm not Gucci I'm just you know I'm
stitch God
[Music]
[Music]
police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shootings in the
city so far this year it's time for
someone to step up and stop them in life
[Music]
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a present and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with a kid
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart there have been no
shootings on that block no shootings no
murders there hasn't even been as much
as a fistfight there's a sense of hope
that they didn't have before it all
because were mothers and you don't want
to underestimate the power of the mother
[Music]